priorité au direct les chées puisque
dans un instant on montrera une vidéo de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
réagi à l'instant euh je vais vous
montrer on va pris les meilleurs moments
de la vidéo on va vous les montrer dans
un instant notamment ed en r Maras a dit
qu'il fallait dégommer physiquement les
insoumis des gens peuvent nous menacer
de mort sans entendre une seule voix
protester contre l'expression d'une
telle violence voilà le pays dans lequel
nous vivons dorénavant donc Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui se pose en victime vous
verrez ça on va prendre les meilleurs
moments de la vidéo il est fort
jean-lucement il est fort mais
ça c'est ça exactement c'est dommage de
mettre autant de force dans le voilà
dans une vidéo vous allez la voir vousz
voir dans un instant juste on va revenir
sur Enrico parce que voulaz revenir
là-dessus de petites secondes Gill pour
mettre faire une petite mise au point
bah je voulais dire surtout à Fran que
vous me faites passer en me regardant
les yeux dans les yeux avec véhémence
presque comme quelqu'un qui a légitimer
les actions odieuses abominables que
j'ai condamné un entendu du et j'ai
condamné ici je
sais indig d'êreque
voilà torqu à Enrico Matias que dire
dégommer physiquement c'est pas bien et
vous pouvez dire qu'il était ému et C il
l'a dit voilà c'est tout non mais je
tenais à dire c jeux pas
pass il s excusé aussi il l'a dit dès le
lendemain matin encore une fois je dis
qu'quun qui dérape et qui s'excuse à
beaucoup moins de culpabilité on va dire
qu' un parti qui affirme et qui assume
c'est un artiste qui a parlé avec son
cœur c'est voilà c'est un mec en plus
enriassa c'est quelqu'un qui a toute sa
vie toute sa carrière été pour la pai et
ché la mor de bien s Viber le cur de
l'humanité et le monde bouleversé
réalise d'un seul coup que la terre
engendre quelquefois des fous on a vu au
palestinen chanter pour la mort de
Rabine juste je vous le rappelle donc
c'est touoursun côté on va pas rentrer
làdedans
encore une fois de pour faire la guerre
de pour faire la
paix a chanté pour la j'attends qu'on a
des
chansons non mais juste Fran si je peux
me permettre aussi là on va rentrer dans
un truc politique dans un truc
historique sachez-le et c'est ce que
j'ai dit hier même la France insoumise
qui arrête pas de parler ils savent pas
du tout quelle est la situation là-bas
ce qui se passe ce qui s'y passe pas
historiquement je suis sûr qu'on peut
les interroger math panneau je pense que
elle arrive même pas à nous sortir
l'histoire donc là là là les mecs je
vous le dire l'opinion publique il faut
arrêter la plupart des gens ne savent
pas ce qui se passe là-bas justement on
va parler des artistes voilà les
personnalités doivent-elles réagir à la
guerre en Israël linchage menace
pression sur les réseaux sociaux des
chanteurs des animateurs des acteurs des
sportifs on a entendu parler Kyan Mbappé
il est où tous les acteurs j'ai vu
auarsy il est où pourquoi il réagit pas
comm la bille fir qui qui réagit enant
palestinien voilà et donc plein de gens
ont demandé pourquoi il y a Gilbert
montagier qui a réagi aussi voilà mais
Thomer SLE a
réagiuraki et regardez ce qu'a dit par
il Arthur qui a poussé un coup de gueule
par exemple regardez
oui je suis un petit peu en colère parce
que mes amis de du métiers sont très
silencieux très discret je ne comprends
pas pourquoi on est là quand il s'agit
de toutes les causes et celle-ci c'est
comme le bataacan quoi donc je je suis
sidéré par le silence de mes de mes
camarades mais il n jamais trop tard
voilà euh donc voilà lui a dit ça euh
Arthur a dit ça moi je vais vous dire ce
que je pense vraiment moi je vais vous
dire chacun et vous allez dire il dit
une phrase bateau mais je dis moi chacun
voit mi à sa porte il faut arrêter un
moment s'il y a des artistes qui veulent
réagir ils le font moi j'ai réagi
pourquoi si je vous dire j'ai une
émission en direct tous les jours j'ai
vu he sur les réseaux tout le monde a
dit pourquoi sir pourquoi sir je réagis
pas moi je vais vous dire j'avais pas
envie juste de faire un post ou de faire
faire un tweet voilà qui serait voilà
j'aurais pas pu m'exprimer pleinement
comme je l'ai fait dans cette émission
donc forcément moi j'étais et je le dis
j'ai aucun mérite moi j'étais obligé de
réagir j'ai une émission en direct tous
les jours je parle d'actualité si je
réagis pas on va dire ce mec là il est
fou Hanouna c'est un guignol voilà donc
forcément je suis obligé de réagir après
Kyan Mbappé je suis désolé les gars moi
je vous dis la vérité Kyan Mbappé les
autres artistes moi c'est des mecs ils
vont vous dire quoi ils vont dire nous
au foot on comprend
pas iléag pour Mor
de
silhabit prent la par pour tout et
n'importe
quoi parce que les gars je dire si c'est
de la nitroglycérine on va
pastir je dis pour eux mais Mo je dis
moi les gars moi les gars je me fais les
l'avocat du diable j'ai parlé à plein de
monde tous les gars ils me disent
comment je fais cyil qu'est-ce que je
fais qu'est-ce que je ils il y a une
telle haine sur les réseaux sociaux qui
se disent si je mets un truc je vais me
faire défoncer j'ai une idée alors j'ai
une idée j'ai réfléchi à cela j'ai fait
une
vidé fait une vidéo je demandais
justement mais vous êtes où vous êtes où
ils sont où j'ai une idée pour c'est
très simple l'idée on le demande pas de
prendre parti on le demande pas de dire
vive Israël on leur demande juste de
dire quelle que soit votre OP le Tor
cont terror pas dire cetterase ils sont
pas cap de la dire un terroriste qui
touche les Français parce qu' y a
français qui sont morts et 18 qui sont
toujours portés pas son age ou donc ça
concerne où vraent quel chose je vous
dire les mecs c'est vrai qu'on leur
demande pas grandchose c'est juste dire
non mais après moi je parle des mecs qui
réagissent à tout je suis assez d'accord
des mecs qui réagissent à tout qui
réagissent j'aV pas vu moi a déjà réagi
sur plein de choses déà r après je dis
leur nom mais peu importe c'est pas eux
précisément mais ceux qui d'habitude
prennent partie et sont de tous les
combats pourquoi pas celui-là qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans celui-là qu'est-ce qu'
est chagrine là c'est pas un combat pour
dire le on leur demande juste de dire ce
que vous voulez dire on condamne les
actes terroristes on est contre le
terrorisme qui soutienent la cause
palestinienne ont une occasion rêver
pourquoi il faut absolument dissocier la
cause palestinienne du Hamas sinon dans
un siècle on se rappellera que c'est les
palestiniens qui ont découpé des têtes
d'enfants alors que c'est le Hamas qui a
pris en otage je pe palestinien depuis
des années donc vous voyez bien que
soutenir la cause et être contre le
terrorisme et mieux que la France
indigne et dire oui on combat contre le
terrorisme d'abord ça permet à
l'Autorité palestinienne de rebondir
mais deuxièmement on parle aux jeunes et
aux jeunes de quartier qui ont été
complètement mais manipulé par les idées
de la France indigne on le sait très
bien et qui essaie d'importer ce conflit
depuis des années parce que je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui il est le temps
justement on a parlit de la violence
pour calmer le jeu comme eux ces stars
là ont l'oreille des jeunes ils ont non
pas le droit mais le devoir de le faire
parce qu'ils ont une responsabilité ils
ont l'oreille des jeunes et en disant
cal mon jeu on est tous unis contre le
terrorisme on évitera la violence dans
notre pays
fait exactement VI il exceptionnel c'est
un mec Vian c'est un mec d'ailleurs mais
Vian il est exceptionnel c'est vrai que
je suis d'accord je suis un peu d'accord
avec vous là-dessus c'est vrai qu'il y a
des mecs ils sont à gométrie variable
ils ont des sensibilités la géométrie
variable voilà et ils choisissent un
petit peu leur cause mais les mecs ils
se disent je vais dire est-ce que ils
ont peur de plus être aimé par une
partie du public est-ce qu'ils ont peur
plus on pe s'il vous plaît de ne plus
amener des gens au cinéma est-ce qu'ils
ont peur de ça est-ce que aujourd'hui le
truc qui est grave c'est ça qui est
grave c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
artistes en
disant non au
terrorismef ils ont peur derrière de se
faire défoncer sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est incroyable et ça
on a la vidéo de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans
un instant vous allez voir sur Enrico
Matas mais ça c'est incroyable ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui tu tu peux pas dire
que tu es contre le terrorisme mais
c'est ça le terrorisme ils font peur si
on a peur même de condamner le
terrorisme ils ont déjà gagné faut
savoir ce qu'on veut comme société
est-ce qu'on laisse aux terroristes le
fait de nous terroriser mentalement ou
est-ce qu'on décide de résister et la
vraie résistance c'est la lutte contre
le terrorisme le has n' Jama un
mouvement résistant arrêz de croire les
réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs ce matin je
sais pas si vous avez vu mais la page
wikipédia du Hamas a été modifiée avant
il y avait marqué mouvement terroriste
et depuis ce matin il y a marqué
mouvement de résistance islamiste depuis
ce matin vérifierors j'ai la photo
Jean-Michel tu voulais r Oui oui parce
que je trouve on a pas 36000 occasions
de d'être un homme dans sa vie donc
quand dans les moments difficiles comme
ça c'est comme ça qu'on bah qu'on prend
position qu'on prend des positions
courageuses même si on peut craindre des
réaction d'un côté un autre parce que
quand la guerre se déclare là pour
l'instant c'est une guerre qui est
régionale qui pourrait s'étendre on sait
jamais on a jamais cru avant chaque
guerre j'avais déjà dit une fois
quelques jours avant déclenchement du
guerre mondiale on savait pas que la
guerre arrivé voilà si le conflit devait
par malheur progressivement se se
s'étendre et ben un moment dans la ligne
de front il y a qu'un il y a que deux
côtés hein on est d'un côté ou d'un
autre il y a plus de oui mais et cetera
non on est d'un côté d'un autre donc à
un moment faut se moi je suis pour que
les gens et ben ils prennent position
voilà après il çatire les foudres de
l'autre partie mais faut moment faut
savoir qui est pour qui et qui est pour
qui donc vous condamnez les artistes qui
ont pas réagi en tout cas moi j'aimerais
bien qu' qu' se mais là bah oui
j'aimerais bien qu' qu' en ait plus qui
se qui se franchement c'est pas
très c'est pas très apaisant ce que tu
dis de devoir choisir un côté ou l'autre
des personnes
prèé persones qui savent pas terrorisme
tu sais ce que c'est quand même bien
s quand il dit faut choisir un camp ou
l'autre person tu V savoir qui va gagner
pour choisir ton camp mais c'est
pas'il plaîil vous pl un pays faut
arrêter de nous tout le temps nous
diviser là moment se rassembler contre
le terrorisme mais après ce que tu dis
c'est choisir un camp ou
l'autre Guill les personnalités
doivent-elles réagir à ce qui s'est
passé non parce que toutes les
personnalités qui se sont positionné on
vient de le voir avec en se retrouve
dans une sauce pas possible je Sun non
vous avez réagi vous avez condamné le
terrorisme évidemment qu'il faut
condamner le terrorisme
par a des personnalités qui ont mis des
drapeaux d'Israël ou de la Palestine qui
se sont retrouvé menacés qui ont
supprimé le
je je n pas néire je pasination
pour
pas juste
réagir dit le terrorisme c'est
horribleème je pense que pourquoi les
artistes doivent pas réagir vous parce
que vous vous avez prononcé le mot c'est
de la nitroglycérine pour eux des
artistes extrêmement fédérateurs mais
non mais je vous dis pourquoi à mon avis
il réagissent
pas non non pas du tout c'est c'est des
très grands des très grandes stars mppé
au Mar alors ils vont peut-être réagir
attention mais en
fait tellement fédérateur ils ont un
public qui est d'un bord à l'autre
qu'ils ne veulent pas prendre le risque
parce qu'ils estim que pour eux ça
pourrait être ou une fin de carrière ou
se priver de la non mais je vous dis pas
qu'ils ont
raison j'explique ce qu'ils font pour
les joueur du PSG c'est extrêmement
compliqué est F fédérateur moi je l'ai
regardé lundi je suis désolé son
discours il était pas du tout il ne
divisait personne donc c'est possible en
tant que que que que voix porte
d'envoyer un message qui positif une
fois G on leur demande pas de dire je
suis pour le gouvernement d'Israël ou je
suis pro israélien et cetera on leur
demande pas ça on leur dit juste vous
dites que je condamne le terrorisme tout
si vous avez raison pourquoi ne le
font-ils pas si vous avez raison
pourquoi ne le fontil pas parce qu'ils
ont peur
on il ont peur il faut le dire vous avez
dit nitroglycérine il on aller
plus ils ont peur de défendre des
victimes juives israen je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi faire SAR limi bien
sûr que des Juifs j'ai organisé avec
Jonathan Béard la réunion au Trocadero
que des Juifs à 95 % il en a mis que des
Juifs ozarora trouvez-moi les photos de
manifestation en France alors que c'est
peut-être une des actions les plus
épouvantable qu'on n jamais sur le sol
français dès qu'il s'agit de victime
juive et ou alors israélienne c'est pire
encore parce que quand on Israël ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'il y a un
traitement différent des victimes c'est
ça la honte les person c'est toutes les
victimes sont traité de la même façon
restons sur les personnalités Delphin
est-ce qu'on peut pas se dire que toutes
les les personnalités qui ne qui ne
réagissent pas là-dessus on va pas tous
dire qu' qu'elles sont pour le
terrorisme justement bien sûr chaque
être humain est contre le terrorisme
c'est une vérité générale donc en fait
il y a pas à le dire à part les monstres
personne n'est pour le terrorisme
mélchon alors vous mon part les monstes
en revanche en revanche pour l'autre
sujet pour l'autre sujet les gens ne
s'expriment pas quand ils ne savent pas
et je trouve que c'est l'intelligence de
pas le faire par rapport non c'est tout
le contraire tout
contrairee fait de rien dire tu
cautionnes d'une certaine façon
aujourd'hi attourh aujourd'ui on fait un
débat et tout mondene pour les trbl de
TER le monde s'inog sur la
questionon personne n'est pour les
tremblements de terre aussi et il y en a
plein qui ont fait des tweets sur le
tremblement de terre au Maroc et c'est
normal norm de l' cha humain et chaque
français on été touché au cur attends on
a les Français on a été touché au cur
par le terrorisme on va trouver un se
français excusemoié on va pas trouver un
seul Français qui est pour le
terrorisme pouroi il réagiss n'orte
quoiuse pas il savent pas rapport de la
Delphine excuse-moi tout le mond est
contre le terrorisme on fait rien non
mais donc on c'est bon SAV tout monde il
vaut mieux ne rien dire comme ça il y a
un fait horrible de terrorisme et donc
du coup c'est bien par omission de ne
rien dire ça veut dire qu'on cautionne
tu pas dire ça ce sont des gens qui
parlent au banlieu demande un petit
gamin s'il rêve pas devant Kilian Mbappé
je veux dire non ces gens-là ont un
devoir ils ont un devoir d'exemplarité
on leur demande pas du tout de faire de
politiques surtout pas moi un conseil en
communication sur un événement comme ça
je leur dis tu tu réagis dans les 24
heures tu as besoin de faire deux mots
il y a des community managers qui savent
faire ça très bien je suis pour la paix
c'est horrible je sais pas des phrases
très non terrorisme et juste pour dire
un truc parce que je me suis pas expimé
tout àure voir sur la question de Méch
et de la France insoumise c'est quand
même un parti C qui nous a aussi dit
qu'il n'était pas tout à fait Charlie
donc on ne peut pas mettre les choses
l'unes en face des autres on peut pas
créer une polémique autour de hrico
Macias qui est le seul artiste alors je
parle pas des hommes de télévision comme
toi puisque tu l'as fait dès lundi matin
mais c'est le seul artiste à avoir eu le
courage cet homme de paix de dire mais
enfin mais c'est pas possible je suis
pour la paix et aujourd'hui on crée
c'est une obè formidable pour la France
insoumise de pouvoir ouvrir une nouvelle
séance de communication
justementement jeanluc mélch vient de
faire une vidéo regardez la vidéo Dean
méchon je la découvre comme vous
sachez-le en direct je la découvre avec
vous ces gensl sont spécialist
man encorefé il y a des gens qui meurent
des bébés il y a eu un
massacre et Jean-Luc Mélenchon il vient
nous faire le gars qui est choqué parce
que Enrico Matias a dit il faut dégommer
la France àise et donc c'estu le drame
du jour l'expression d'une telle
violence j'ai cru un moment que pour une
fois son humanité all revenir
mais parattent il
Parr CIS personne parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est expert en TER en
matière de manipulation mentale de la
manipulation de l'opinion d'essayer de
faire maintenant de Enrico Maas le
centre du débat pardon mais c'est une
honte en conférence de avec un ton gra
comme ça en parlant de violence enfin
mais des bébés qui ont été décapités et
je je te regarde pas du
tout non mais par défaut je te regarde
mais je ve je veux dire ici que en effet
dès lundi matin dès lundi soir pardon tu
as condamné absolument tout ça les
réactions sont profitez de ça pour faire
de la politique et à vomir non mais
Jean-Luc Mélenchon là il était il était
où là il était dans un Chalier là en
train de faire non mais qu'est-ce qu'il
fait là non mais s qu'il aille faire des
crêpes non mais franchement qu'il aille
faire des crêpes au Grand Marnier là
sans rigoler est revenu ça y est non
mais franchement là il vient de
déchausser là il était au ski il a dit
je vais faire un discours mais arrêté
jeanluc Mélenchon il éta en train de
boire un vinchaud il en a bu un petit
peu trop là sans déconna qu'est-ce qu'il
peut non mais c'est quoi ça Jean je
crois qu'il est devenu fou excusez-moi
de vous dire ça non mais g qu'est-ce tu
pensoui alors il a toujours une tendance
paranoïac jeanluc Mélenchon toujours
c'est-à-dire que c'est lui contre la
terre entière et donc là effectivement
je suis d'accord il joue sur cette
stratégie pour tenter de récupérer ce
qui peut l'être parce que c'est vrai que
François Ruffin leur a mis un grand coup
de pied dans la gueule quand même avec
une altitud très digne en disant
peut-être que sur le fond on a été nul
globalement c'est ce qu'il dit donc là
il tente de reprendre l'ascendant il le
fait très maladroitement il suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous c'est pas
digne d'un candidat à la présidence il
il parle plus de d'Enrico Matias que des
drames qui se
passent rendez compte de faire une
conférence de presse pour parler
d'Enrico maias non mais les gars jou il
joue le coup d'après comme vous l'aviez
dit dès lundi de
l'électoralisme du clientélisme des
banlieux en tentant y a ça mais il y a
aussi une bataille interne il y a une
bataille interne puisque en face de lui
il y a
effectivement Hain et Ruffin qui sont en
train de prendre du poids à l'intérieur
de la France insoumise donc c'est de la
politique mais comprend comme j'ag s'il
vous plaît Pascal donnez votre avis s'il
vous plaît làdessus j'aimerais bien avir
vot av je suis
extrêmement surprise d'abord de des mots
de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon comment peut-il
tenir un tel discours après tout
effectivement ce déferernement qu'il y a
eu moi j'ai du mal à comprendre la
position de la France insoumise moi je
je suis désolé du terrorisme c'est du
terrorisme quel qu'il soit je ne
comprends pas comment on narrive pas à
le condamner je comprends pas que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce soir continue sur
sur la même ligne alors je vais vous
dire on va parler dans un instant aussi
des autres personnalités qui ont réagi
vous allez voir Géraldine quand tu vois
ça ah moi je suis pas du tout surprise
en fait c'est un bon moment qu' sont
indignes qui sont absèes et qui sont
agerbé moi j'oublierai jamais de ce qu'a
dit Monsieur Mélenchon et et je l'avais
dit je l'ai dit hier sur l'attentat de
Mohamed Mera en avec une sorte de de
vocable un peu complotiste absolument
immonde voilà il a des sortes de
changements aussi alors il était avant
totalement contre la BA maintenant il
est complètement pour la baaya il a
aucune colonne vertébrale il est il est
à gerbé vraiment c'est c'est horrible
non mais c'est incro s vous plaî est-ce
qu'on peut le revoir j'aimerais qu'on le
revoie avec vous parce que je ve revoir
le début et je vous jure qu'au début je
me suis dit ah il va condamner les
attlentas et là il parle d'un truc il
part sur Enrico Matias je vous jure j'ai
l'impression que c'est l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai l'impression que
c'estotot IOT
qui ceite une parodie regardez on
aimerait tellement nous sommes sans
doute nombreux dans cette salle avoir eu
et en avoir encore de l'affection comme
Enrico maassas dire qu'il faut dégommer
les LFI et voir aussitôt pulluler les
commentaires pour préciser qu'on parle
bien de les dégommer
physiquement faisant peser sur nous des
menaces de mort que nous recevons
quasiment tous les jours voir des gens
nous menacer de mort sans entendre une
seule voix protester contre L'Express
d'une telle violence voilà le pays dans
lequel nous vivons et évidemment
qu'est-ce qui vaut ce que nous sommes en
train de faire en ce moment montrer que
personne ne nous fait peur c'est bon
c'est mais mais comment on peut dire ça
aujourd'hui personne ne nous fait peur
il y a il y a eu des massacres il dit
personne ne nous fait peur qu'est-ce qu'
va faire jeanl
M parle de menace de mort menace de mort
avec les Juifs de France vous savez le
genre de message qui reçoivent j'ai
juste partagé la photo de la tour avec
le drapeau israélien j'aiç menaces mais
on est chez les fous et c'est lui la
victime on a l'impression qu'il va
utiliser le mot terrorisme pour parler
de ce qui lui arrive à lui il touour pas
utilisé le mot terrorisme pour parler de
ce qui passé Enrico terroriste c'est pas
loin il est en train de traiter Enrico
de terroriste non mais c'est incroyable
quand tu dis Enrico Enrico Maas quand il
dit Enrico Maas la violence d'Enrico
Maas nous n'avons peur de personne mais
de quoi il met un coup de pression à
Enrico Maas il il a pas saisi cette
instant d'émotion cet instant de
compassion quel que soient les opinions
politiques quel que soient les débats il
s'agit pas de polique fois DEP l moi
j'ai pris une grande décision et je va
vous la dire dans
inst j'ai pris une grande décision là
concernant tout ça je vais vous la
donner dans un instant jeis vous la dire
dans un instant et et d'ailleurs ça me
pose un petit problème dont je vais vous
parler dans quelques minutes à tout de
suite